[Applause]
these actors and actresses clearly
understood the assignment when it came
to creating the perfect voice for these
iconic characters
from unusual inspiration replicating
accents or sound engineering
we all know that tom hardy plays eddie
brock in the venom films and that it is
his voice behind the symbiotic venom but
what fans may not know is that it's more
than just hardy behind the voice of the
anti-hero hardy claims that the voice he
made for venom was a combination of
redman busta rhymes and james brown
that's where the sound department came
in they worked relentlessly to trigger
the voice i'd have to lay down the
vocals for venom in the morning and then
play eddie opposite in my earpiece the
late voice actor brad venable also
contributed to the voice of venom in the
first film
gollum is easily one of the most iconic
characters in the entire lord of the
rings franchise and it was his work as
the demented golem that made him a go-to
actor for characters that required
motion capture even from interviews
circus typically speaks with a lot of
elegance which makes his golem voice all
the more surprising circus found
inspiration for the voice in his own
home they basically impersonate my cat
particularly circus based the voice
around how his cat would hack up
any
hairballs
many were surprised when it was
announced that american actress kristen
stewart would play the highly coveted
role of princess diana in the film
spencer stewart ended up working with
the same dialect coach that the crown
star emma coren worked with when she
played diana in the fourth season of the
crown the accent is intimidating as all
hell because people know that voice and
it's so so distinct in particular
stewart ended up wowing critics with her
diana voice which likely lifted a giant
burden of stress off her shoulders well
they killed me do you think
there was quite a bit of hype
surrounding margot robbie when she was
cast as the fan favorite dc character
harley quinn in suicide squad she's got
a very high pitch voice which for the
light-hearted stuff the crazy stuff
works really well but when it's a pretty
raw emotional scene you lose the gravity
when you're speaking in such a high
voice robbie's voice drew inspiration
from multiple places combining a
brooklyn tinge with lorraine bronco's
performance in goodfellas and lastly
harley's voice in batman the animated
series
i never said that
to create his batman voice robert
pattinson didn't necessarily look at the
work of the other batman for inspiration
but instead he drew inspiration from his
the lighthouse co-star willem dafoe who
used a pirate-like accent willem's voice
in the lighthouse was quite inspiring
for it to be honest it is pretty similar
the voice i'm gonna do to willems i'm
vengeance
while johnny depp's interpretation of
willy wonka in charlie and the chocolate
factory may be polarizing to both fans
of depp as well as fans of gene wilder
there's no doubt that dapp definitely
knew what he was doing depp's wonka
voice came to him while he was playing
with his then six-year-old daughter lily
rose depp would often practice different
voices while playing with barbies with
his young daughter and often times his
daughter would tell him to stop then we
were playing one day and i started to
use my wonka voice and she kind of lit
up a bit like where's that coming from
and i thought all right i think i'm on
the right track here
i never expected to have so much income
thor ragnarok presented a new
opportunity while playing the hulk for
actor mark ruffalo while in previous
live-action incarnations lou ferrigno
provided his vocals to the hulk ruffalo
for the first time had to do a voice for
the hulk i hulk like fire the sound
technicians would later on make
ruffalo's hulk voice sound a bit more
monstrous ruffalo still wanted to give
credit to his predecessor though that's
who i watched playing the hulk growing
up it's definitely a nod to you lou you
influenced that
dog
christian bale's growling and gravelly
batman voice in the dark knight trilogy
has since become synonymous with the
character the voice came to bail almost
by coincidence during his audition for
the role he had to wear vel kilmer's bat
suit from batman forever which initially
made him feel ridiculous but then gave
him an idea if you look at the history
of the guy and the pain he went through
i went i can't do this in a normal voice
i have to become a beast in order to
sell this to myself
when bale showed off his voice to his
wife hoping to impress her she laughed
suggesting that the audition was a
failure luckily it wasn't and the rest
was history you made a serious mistake
rami malek had a lot of weight on his
shoulders when stepping into the role of
late queen frontman freddie mercury in
bohemian rhapsody mercury had such a
distinct singing voice that it was
obvious malik regardless of how talented
of an actor he is couldn't pull off the
voice alone
malik's mercury singing voice was
actually a mix of his own mercury's
vocals and mark martel who is known for
his covers of classic queen songs this
ultimately paid off in the end as malik
went on to win best actor at the oscars
for the role yes of course
tom hardy's interpretation of the
classic batman villain bane in the dark
knight rises is quite different from how
he's portrayed in the comics which meant
that hardy had to create a new kind of
voice for the villain because of the
villain's latino origins artie looked
into famous latin figures and stumbled
across bartley gorman a bare-knuckle
fighter who was known as the king of the
gypsies hardy showed director
christopher nolan and said that either
they do a typical monotone villain voice
or try out the accent even if they end
up regretting it nolan ultimately agreed
to let hardy try out the accent and it
was a success
gotham is yours
until recently most associated daniel
craig with the british suave he pulls
off while playing bond but with his role
as benoit blanc in knives out fans saw a
whole different side of craig as he
spoke in a thick southern accent the
idea of having a southern accent came to
craig while reading the script after
talking to director ryan johnson for
inspiration for the voice craig looked
at civil war historian shelby foote
whose voice craig heard in a ken burns
documentary we were talking about oh we
want it to be sonorous and honey we
didn't want it to be twangy and annoying
so shelby foot came to mind
a donut hole in a donuts hole lupita
nyong'o gave a powerhouse duel
performance in jordan peels us and
audiences were taken aback by the voice
she used when portraying red the
supposed tethered version of her
character i was inspired by the
condition spasmodic dysphonia which is a
condition that comes about from trauma
sometimes emotional sometimes physical
it creates this spasming in your vocal
cords that leads to an irregular flow of
air he had to eat rabbit
and bloody
samuel l jackson's villainous valentine
in kingsman the secret service notably
has a lisp something we don't really see
from jackson i did the lisp because
people tend to dismiss people who have
defects in interesting sorts of ways and
especially speech defects jackson was
not only inspired by the lisp he had in
his childhood but also from tv host
jonathan ross who ironically is the
husband of the film's screenwriter jane
goldman you know what this is like kate
winslet impressed audiences with her
accurate eastern pennsylvanian accent
when playing mareshian in mayor of east
town it is absolutely up there amongst
the top two hardest dialects i've ever
done winslet said that she struggled the
most with getting the o's right as well
as how the people of eastern
pennsylvania often smoosh their words
together so it's not like a voice that
you hear the actor doing it just
evaporates everyone's having dinner over
there because he's a big cook all of a
sudden and no one's coming to my
ceremony is that it
sercia ronan is one of the most gifted
young actresses in hollywood and her
title role in greta gerwig's lady bird
is perhaps one of her most beloved roles
ronan struggled a bit with nailing down
her character's sacramento accent but
after guidance from gerwig ronan was
able to get it down it's a lot sort of
flatter and more laid back and the fact
that it's sunnier for longer in the year
and it's warmer and things like that
that probably has an effect on how these
people sound i i like your band
with jonah ruiz even the smallest
accents can be tricky to pull off and
these actors and actresses were able to
defy the odds and give us some pretty
seamless accents
what's your favorite voice in a movie
[Music]